so there's a new trainer for Godzilla I
love this trailer a lot I really like
this trailer I walked away from this
trailer so pumped it engaged me I was
like yeah before I was looking forward
to Godzilla now I'm like I really want
to see Godzilla a lot first of all they
played it right Bryan Cranston's voice
is in the forefront of this entire
trailer he's only in his Heisenberg
voice he's like what happened out there
wasn't an earthquake it's not a typhoon
it is the danger it's the one who knocks
he's probably right Godzilla is like
burn your world down just me they have a
really interesting and cool plot point
back in the 60s this Godzilla was you
know raising havoc apparently not a lot
of havoc cuz no one knows about him it
looks like he was wrecking unknown
islands or some [ __ ] and then try to
nuke him they try to take him out maybe
they did maybe they didn't maybe this is
his kid maybe it's him but he's more
powerful because he was like hey thanks
for the nuke now I'm stronger point is
Godzilla is back and he's huge this
trailer this movie shows that Godzilla
is a force to be reckoned with he's so
much bigger than any other Godzilla
we've ever seen which is cool a lot of
people were like that's why you over
powerful I think it's actually a good
play because you have to establish this
thing is damn near unbeatable reason
that's important is because of theory a
lot of people have a lot of people who
are down with the Godzilla lore they've
seen a couple shots in this trailer and
you're like that's Rodin or rode on one
of the two iconic flying Godzilla
pterodactyl badass you see in the movie
I have no idea but you do see a couple
things that makes you think there's
something else other than Godzilla in
this trailer one that thing that lands
in the water what is it I have no idea
but it lands in the water Godzilla fans
I've seen comment they're like dust
Rodin because I grew up on Godzilla and
it falls like Rodin it flies like Rodin
until I see otherwise until I am proven
wrong that's what that is but also that
one scene where we're on a ship and all
these planes are falling from the sky
well this eerie music scraping up
Brendan it could be running into
Godzilla but they're not crashing in
anything they're not burning they're
just falling and there is a shot that
establishes that when Godzilla's in the
water he's under the water this
something is in the clouds something is
up there I think it's something other
than Godzilla which now we get into
Pacific Rim territory or actually
Pacific Rim borrowed from Godzilla I get
that point is they're throwing it back
they're like Godzilla is huge he's
overpowered we're not going to be able
to beat him what do we need I don't know
another Godzilla thing to beat
Godzilla's and then we have a
flying pterodactyl it's gonna fight him
I don't know for sure this is why we
make these videos we theorize this
sounds awesome
I love that scene where a bunch of
Marines come across this radioactive
thing this canister that has this white
foam on the outside this guy's all he
wipes the foam away I'm like yeah go
ahead and touch that that's smart you
know when you have balls growing out of
your head you got no one to blame but
yourself we see a couple of really cool
shots of Godzilla we see his fins it's
one scene where you see the front of him
he's like just head-on he opens his
mouth he's either roaring or he's gonna
breathe his atomic breath on people I'd
be down with either but I really want
him to have his atomic breath cut so
it's gotta breathe fire and [ __ ] he's
got it I was impressed with this trailer
godzilla looks huge godzilla looks
badass oh it looks like mankind is
coming to an end that's what I want from
this I don't want to see it like a minor
inconvenience like well I guess that one
city's wiped out but in the end
Ozymandias from Watchmen did a lot more
snow I want to feel like mankind if they
don't get this thing in check is gonna
get wiped out if not wiped out we're all
gonna be in caves with our rock so like
there were that big lizard yeah that's a
good story
ask your grandfather I'm gonna get this
fire built one day so that Godzilla
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it do you think that's Rodin
fighting Godzilla whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]
you